I was recently asked a shailoh that someone
who's going to Eretz Yisrael for Pesach with
a bunch of family, and the family is
keeping only one day of Yom Tov, and
he wanted to know what the halacha is,
should he keep two days of Yom Tov
or should he keep one day of Yom
Tov? So, this is a significantly complicated and
controversial area of halacha. I just want to
go through the basics with you and hopefully
we'll come to some clear decision, but again,
obviously halacha l'maise, every shailoh has so many
little nuances of difference that you need to
ask a shailoh each time. You can't, not
necessarily each time, but you need to ask
a shailoh. Each individual case needs to ask
a shailoh. You can't always assume that two
cases are the same. Obviously, the history of
it is that bizman that they used to
be mekadesh hachodesh al pi r'ia, word didn't
get out to everybody quickly enough to know
exactly when Rosh Chodesh is, and therefore there
was a sfeika d'yoma. They weren't sure which
day to keep Yom Tov, so in galus,
they kept two days of Yom Tov to
be sure. Even after the zman Amoraim, at
the time when they were no longer mekadesh
al pi r'ia, the Gemara Masechet Beitzah Daf
daled amud bais tells us that they still
continued to do Yom Tov Sheini shel Galuyos
even though there's a set calendar and we
know which day is the first day of
Yom Tov, but still minhag avoseinu b'yadeihem, we
continue to keep two days of Yom Tov.
That's the very basic background to two days
of Yom Tov. Now, there is a major
machlokes Rishonim whether that issue of minhag avoseinu
b'yadeihem is just a minhag or it's a
din d'rabbanan, it's a takana mi-d'rabbanan. But whatever
it is, it has to be kept. However
you want to understand the details of it,
Yom Tov Sheini shel Galuyos we don't question
anymore. The fact that we keep two days
of Yom Tov here in galus is a
davar pashut. The interesting issue becomes when someone
from Chutz La'aretz travels to Eretz Yisrael, or
really vice versa, someone from Eretz Yisrael comes
to Chutz La'aretz. There is a Mishna Masechet
Pesachim Daf nun where the Mishna tells us
that someone who goes from a makom that
has certain minhagim to a makom that has
different minhagim is supposed to keep the chumros
of the makom that he came from as
well as the chumros of the makom that
he went to. He should keep the chumros
of both places. The particulars of that Mishna
is talking about doing melacha in erev Pesach,
that there were some places that a minhag
they didn't do melacha in erev Pesach, other
places that had a minhag that they did
do melacha in erev Pesach. You go from
one makom to the other, you keep the
chumros. You go, you keep the chumros of
the place of both places. However, the Gemara
over there in daf nun aleph says that
if a person plans on staying where he
is, the Gemara says that someone is still
limited to all the issurim of the place
that he left only if he plans on
going back. But if he plans on staying
where he is, the new makom that he
came, so then he becomes a ben makom
of the makom that he went to and
he now has all the halachos of that
makom and all the minhagim of that makom.
So if someone went, let's say, from Chutz
La'aretz to Eretz Yisrael, just because he was
born in Chutz La'aretz doesn't mean that he's
forever limited or bound by the Chutz La'aretz
chumros, let's say. So he would keep whatever
they keep in Eretz Yisrael if he plans
on making aliya, he plans on staying there.
If you plan on staying, you don't have
da'as lachzor, so then your halacha changes. So
the question over here is how does this
apply to Yom Tov Sheini or does it
apply to Yom Tov Sheini? Meaning, maybe we
should say the same thing. You have someone
who goes from Chutz La'aretz to Eretz Yisrael,
plans on coming back, so just apply that
Gemara, and therefore the halacha should be he
keeps the chumros of both places, keeps the
chumros of Eretz Yisrael and the chumros of
Chutz La'aretz. Or do you say, maybe no,
maybe there's reason to say that we shouldn't
apply this Gemara? So, in the Teshuvos Avkas
Rochel, which was written by Rav Yosef Karo
in Siman Chaf Vov, he paskens that we
do apply the concepts in the Gemara in
Pesachim, the Mishna in Pesachim of applying the
chumros of both places, and therefore he says
when a ben Chutz La'aretz goes to Eretz
Yisrael and plans on returning, he does need
to keep all the chumros and he's got
to keep two days of Yom Tov. That's
meforash in the teshuva of the Bais Yosef
in Avkas Rochel. And he even goes so
far as to say that it was a
minhag that that's what everyone did, that the
minhag used to always be that people would
gather and have Yom Tov Sheini minyanim where
they davened tefillos of Yom Tov in Eretz
Yisrael. So that's what people always did, that's
not a chiddush. He didn't view that as
like something that's against the minhag. He said
that's what people always did when they went
from Chutz La'aretz to Eretz Yisrael. And in
fact, that's the way most of the poskim
seem to say. Mishnah Berurah in Taf Tzaddik
Vav Sif Kattan yud gimmel, Rav Moshe in
a couple of teshuvos in Orach Chaim Chelek
Gimmel Siman Ayin daled and Chelek daled Siman
chaf ches. This is something that seems to
be widely accepted among the poskim. However, there
is a significant shitta, which interestingly when you
look at Rav Moshe's teshuvos, he doesn't even
quote this shitta, it's like he's not even
gores it, but the shitta of the Chacham
Tzvi, which is a very well-known shitta and
has pretty cogent logic. The Chacham Tzvi in
Siman kuf samech zayin was asked this question,
and he says no, you can't apply the
Gemara in Pesachim at all. The Gemara in
Pesachim is talking about minhagim that theoretically could
be can apply in any place, but for
whatever reason the bnei hamakom in a certain
place keep a certain minhag and in another
place they don't keep a certain minhag. So
then we say, okay, keep the chumra even
when you go from point A to point
B, keep the chumra of point A even
though you're now in place B. Still you
keep the chumra. That makes sense if it's
a chumra that theoretically could have been observed
anywhere. But over here it's not a chumra
that could have been observed anywhere. Yom Tov
Sheni is a din that's only shayach to
chutz la'aretz. It's something that only makes sense
in chutz la'aretz. And Eretz Yisrael doesn't even
make sense, they never would have kept Yom
Tov Sheni in Eretz Yisrael. So says Rav
Yosef, I'm still in shiur mode, says the
Chacham Tzvi, what we see from there is
that it seems you should not apply this
mishna at all, and therefore he says if
someone is visiting Eretz Yisrael and he's a
ben chutz la'aretz, he only keeps one day
of Yom Tov. This has been accepted by
some of the later acharonim, by some of
the mainstream acharonim. Shulchan Aruch HaRav, I assume
this is what Lubavitchers do, Shulchan Aruch HaRav
writes in siman tav-tzadi-vav os yud-aleph, he writes
bnei chutz la'aretz shebau le'eretz yisrael af al
pi shedaatan lachzor, even though they plan on
going back home to chutz la'aretz to chutz
la'aretz, shouldn't call it ein osin ela yom
echad k'vnei eretz yisrael. They still only keep
one day like bnei eretz yisrael. And then
he writes like an afterthought, v'yeish cholkin, there
are those who disagree. But the stam deiah
that's quoted in Shulchan Aruch HaRav is that
you keep one day. That is the shita
of the Chacham Tzvi, but it's certainly if
you read through poskim, it seems to be
a significant minority shita, does not seem to
be the majority shita. Now then there's a
third shita. Many of you may have heard
of the one and a half, and there
are various variations of what one and a
half means. What one and a half does
not mean is you keep one day and
then the other day till chatzos. That it
certainly does not mean. One and a half
means the following, and this is a shita
that's quoted by Rebbi Yechiel Michel Tukachinsky in
his Ir HaKodesh VeHaMikdash perek yud-tes, and it's
something that everyone quotes beshem Rav Soloveitchik. Rav
Soloveitchik held this way as well, and he
had to worry about this himself. He only
went to Eretz Yisrael I think one time
in the 1930s when he was trying out
for Chief Rabbi of Tel Aviv. So I
think he was there for a Shavuos. So
he asked his father, he asked Rav Moshe
Soloveitchik what to do. So this is what
he told him to do. He said, look,
Chacham Tzvi is right. He said his logic
is so good, you gotta say that he's
correct. But since the majority of poskim say
against the Chacham Tzvi, you can't just dismiss
the other shitos. And therefore you should pasken
like the Chacham Tzvi but be machmir for
the other deious, which means that take sides
and assume that really there's really only one
day of Yom Tov, but be machmir not
to do melacha on the second day. You
should be machmir in both directions. But whenever
the chumra has to—like every chumra, with every
chumra comes a kula the chumra presents a
conflict between day one and day two, always
lean toward day one because that's the real
halacha. So for instance, after the first night
of Yom Tov you hear havdala from an
Israeli who's making havdala and you don't say
kiddush because you don't want to say a
bracha levatala so you're not going to say
kiddush because you really hold be'etzem it's only
one day. On the day after Yom Tov
rishon you say tfillos shel chol because you
gotta decide which tfillos you're going to say,
so on the second day of Yom Tov
say tfillos shel chol because you pasken like
the Chacham Tzvi. On Shemini Atzeret you don't
eat in the sukka. All these types Pesach
sedarim are a very complicated issue exactly what
you do. He has a whole, Rebbi Yechiel
Michel Tukachinsky gives a whole presentation of all
these details what to do. That's what Rav
Soloveitchik paskened. I once asked Rav Schachter about
this, he said he paskens the exact opposite.
He said, \"That's what Rav Soloveitchik held.\" He
said, \"I hold that really me'ikar hadin it's
two days, but it's kedai to be machmir
for the shitos that it's one day.\" So
you would davven tfillos shel Yom Tov but
you would still have to put on tefillin
just without a bracha. So it would be
a whole separate twist to which direction you
would go. That's the third shita. Now there
are a couple of X-factors over here. X-factor
number one is what does daatan lachzor mean?
The Radbaz writes in a tshuva and this
is accepted by the Mishna Berura in tav-tzadi-vav
seif katan yud-gimmel that if you go with
your entire family then you're not considered daatan
lachzor. Because who's going to go with their
entire family and not fall in love with
Eretz Yisrael and just want to stay there?
Meaning if you go without your family, okay
you have something pulling you back. But you
go with your entire family, then it's not
daatan lachzor. So Rav Moshe writes that that's
ridiculous to apply to our times where you
bought a return ticket and you get home
in ten hours and like very few people
go and then just stay. It's interesting, Rav
Nosson Gestetner writes in a tshuva that when
he went to Eretz Yisrael in whatever it
was, 1950, or whatever it was, when he
went—it was before that, I think it was
even before World War II—when he went to
Eretz Yisrael for a visit, he started learning
in yeshiva there and he loved it so
much he decided right there on the spot
on Yom Tov. It happened to have been
on Yom Tov, it was I think it
was on Shavuos, he... decided I'm staying. Now
he didn't know what to do. When he
started Yom Tov he was going to keep
two days, but he didn't know what to
do: should I keep a second day? Because
he decided right then and there that he's
staying. He went to ask the Chazon Ish.
I don't remember what the, what the answer
the Chazon Ish gave him. But that's, you
know, if that, that were a legitimate possibility,
then when you go with your whole family,
that's, that's the shita that holds that, that
that's called already that it's not daato lachzor
and then you would keep only one day.
Aruch HaShulchan writes that if you plan on
staying for at least a year, then it's,
then you would only keep one day, which
would have a big nafka mina for guys
who go to learn for a year. Ella
mai, guys don't really go to learn for
a year anymore. Guys go for a couple
of months, then they come home, you know,
for a wedding, for their cousin's wedding, and
for Chanukah because they need a Chanukah present
and a hug and then they go, you
know, for Pesach again and whatever. So no
one, no one really goes for a full
year anymore. But if you were to literally
go for a full year, Aruch HaShulchan thinks
that you would only keep, you would only
keep one day. Rav Ovadia Yosef thinks that
if you're a bachur of marriageable age who's
single and you're in Eretz Yisrael learning in
yeshiva, Rav Ovadia writes in a teshuva in
Yabia Omer chelek vav Orach Chayim siman mem
and Yechaveh Da'at chelek aleph siman chof vav
you keep one day because even though you're
not dating right now, chances are, not chances
are, but there's a possibility you'll meet a
nice Israeli girl and you're going to want
to stay in Eretz Yisrael. Unless you're absolutely
adamant that under no circumstances are you going
to date an Israeli girl. Then maybe, then
maybe it would be different. I'm not making
this up. So that's X-factor number one. X-factor
number two is Rav Schachter. He told me
a number of years ago that he was
very disturbed that rumors started going around that
Rav Schachter holds that if you go in
a large group, you only keep one day.
He said that's not at all what I
hold. Let me tell you what happened. A
large group of people were going from California.
A group of 250 people. The rabbi called
me up and he said 200 of these
250 people are not going to ask me
what to do. They're going to keep one
day no matter what. What should I tell
the other 50 to do? And they're going
as a group, they're doing everything together. So
Rav Schachter said he thought in that situation
where 200 of them are anyway going to
keep one day, it would be a violation
of Lo Titgodedu to have different people doing
different things. They're all in the same situation,
they should all do the same thing. So
he said l'halacha they should all keep two
days, l'chumra, two days and then one day
l'chumra. But they're not. So if you're in
a group where the large majority are keeping
one day, so he thought that because of
Lo Titgodedu that you should, you should conform
to what everybody, to what everybody else is
doing. But it's a very tricky thing. I
had a balebos, for instance, who was going
with his parents. His parents own an apartment
in Eretz Yisrael and they keep one day,
they got a psak from whoever they got
it from, and he went to Eretz Yisrael
for Shavuos. So he asked Rav Schachter, \"What
do you think in this situation? Lo Titgodedu?
No, he's going with his whole family, they're
all keeping one day. He said no, the
parents own an apartment in Eretz Yisrael, he
doesn't. So they're in a different situation. When
there's a different matzav for different members of
the family, so then you wouldn't say Lo
Titgodedu. Lo Titgodedu is everyone in the same
boat should do the same thing, but they're
in two different boats over here. I'm just
mentioning this because you have to realize that
there are so many little nuances in each
case that a shayla has to be asked
in each and every situation. In terms of
the shayla that was asked recently to me,
I'll deal with that personally. But these are
just some of the basic, the basic overview.